this research also does have particular
applications for the Armed Forces I
think it was a dr. Lewis is ova he's on
the founder of the of a center for
enhanced training at West Point and he
said that I know time other than today
has there been a greater demand for the
army to invest in and it means to
regulate alertness and what he means by
this is that there's all types of the
Army's requiring all types of advanced
technology they have likely to the
soldier if you'd be looking at a GPS
device then he'd be looking up a broad
broad field so like a broad view in the
real world so you're going from a narrow
focus to a wife or focus it requires a
lot of visual attention skills
definitely air traffic controllers when
I visited the Federal Aviation
Administration I was shocked like
there's all all interfaces going on the
same with pilots you're going from
looking at interfaces to looking out so
so there's a lot of things that require
visual attention skills and training of
that and I think that's what they're
they're interested in so when I when I
present it I presented to the fort
monmouth the armed forces communications
electronics association and when i
present it to them a lot of people asked
me to forward their paper so i think
definitely more research we have to be
done looking into how acupressure trains
alertness over time if you could apply
acupressure for longer or shorter
periods of time how that would affect if
there's certain points that are more
effective so they're definitely looking
into that and i mean it would be a long
process for them to impose implement
acupressure training into the armed
forces but it's definitely something
that there's a lot of interest in that
we might one day see